he was a wide-eyed teenager when he
started at yorkshire but joe root is now
one of the finest batsmen on the planet
he's about to lead england on an ash's
tour but within his 14 years at
headingley he played alongside azim
rafiq who has described the club as
institutionally racist you've been at
this club since 2007. can you
say here today that you've never
heard or experienced or been aware of
any of the racism that other colleagues
have talked about
not from my not that i can recall no no
i can't
but the thing is what i will say is it's
clear that there's the things have
happened at the club and
we have to make sure that we you know we
eradicate it and you know we look to
find ways of making sure that this never
happens again in sport azeem rafiq
tweeted this afterwards disappointed is
not even the feeling incredibly hurt but
uncomfortable truths are hard to accept
it seems
yorkshire's chief executive mark arthur
who has run this club during this
scandal has now quit in his resignation
statement he failed to mention azeem
rafiq or racism
he hasn't acknowledged it but it was
impossible for mark arthur to stay he is
still expected to give evidence before
mps on tuesday as is azim rafiq and it
is very likely there will be further
accusations of racism
the club's new chairman lord patel
welcomed the latest resignation and has
said seismic change here must start from
within it's clear that cricket does have
a problem that it hasn't tackled up to
date and this is a bit of a watershed
moment really
and it's time that it was called out
wherever it is seen across the game
because this isn't good for
participation or for engaging with all
sorts of communities in a game that
should be for all
as the england captain joe root is
calling for people to re-educate
themselves in cricket particularly at
his club where racism has gone
unpunished a culture that he says he was
not aware of
tom parmenter sky news headingley